[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi d'être face
à vous aujourd'hui
quand on m'a invité pour ce ted et qu'on
m'a donné le thème donc embrasser
l'inconnu ça a tout de suite convoquer
une notion importante pour moi c'est la
notion de liberté
j'ai fait une école de bosa j'ai même
fréquenté trois écoles de beaux-arts en
cinq ans et après ce cursus et bien j'ai
enseigné pendant une année puis j'ai
postulé à des résidences des bourses ce
qui fait qu'à 24 23 ans j'ai commencé à
vivre de mon art assure vivre de mon art
et dont je voyageais énormément de
résidence en résidence où j'étais
accueilli pendant deux trois six mois et
j'ai eu le temps de développer un
protocole d'action c'est à dire qu'à
chaque fois je j'appliquais le même
système un peu comme un scientifique
c'est à dire que je rencontrais les
différentes personnalités qui est
importante dans la ville en question ou
dans le lieu j'ai étudié le patrimoine
l'histoire et jean déduisait une oeuvre
que je produisais que je donnais à voir
et donc j'allais chercher une autre
résidence et ainsi de suite voilà donc
je survivais comme ça pendant quelques
années et tout le monde était assez
admiratif de ça on me disait mais quelle
chance tu es si jeune et déjà tu arrives
à enchaîner les projets à montrer ton
travail donc j'étais porté aussi par
une distinction sociale et un jour un
homme qui n'était pas un ami mais qui
connaissait bien mon travail m'a fait
une réflexion il m'a dit mais je
comprends pas ton travail pour moi tu es
à l'opposé de ce que devrait être un
artiste du voyage beaucoup je rencontre
plein de gens et tu t'adaptes tout le
temps aux conditions alors qu'un artiste
c'est quelqu'un qui devrait nous faire
voyager c'est quelqu'un qui devraient
transporter son univers et nous l'offrir
toi tu fais linverse tu t'adaptes ça
peut paraître anodin mais cette
réflexion a complètement bouleversé ma
conception de l'artiste est donc mon
statut et mon identité sauf quand vous
êtes dans un 1 circuit comme ça de
résidence de bourse il est difficile de
s'en extraire c'est comme quand vous
êtes à vélo et bien si vous cessez de
pédaler vous pouvez plus avancées et
vous risquez de tomber sauf que là il y
avait une nécessité fallait vraiment que
je m'arrête donc j'ai décidé de
m'extraire de toussaint et de retourner
vivre chez mes parents surtout comment
ça fait dix ans vous avez quitté le
domicile familial et que vous demandez à
vos parents de revenir alors déjà faut
mettre son ego de côté
c'est difficile surtout quand on est
artiste et puis faut avoir des parents
extrêmement
conciliant voyez pas sûr donc ça ça a
été une épreuve difficile mais
nécessaire et qui m'appelle rémy est
d'expérimenter d'autres casquettes j'ai
été commissaire d'exposition j'étais
critique d'art tout en essayant de
développer bas mon travail puisque
j'avais le temps dans le temps oui non
j'étais quand même dans une urgence de
but n'était pas de rester chez mes
parents éternellement sachant que vous
avez quitté à 17h
puis la chance m'a souri
à la chance m'a souri la chance ça se
provoque j'ai fait une demande
d'ateliers logement à la ville de paris
cinq ans auparavant et sans réponse sans
suite et ce qui a tout bouleversé c'est
que j'ai eu le contact au ministère de
la culture de la personne chargée des
logements pour artistes donc j'ai
contacté j'ai écrit un mail je lui ai
envoyé un dossier mon cv et il m'a reçu
en entretien et pendant cet entretien la
ville a compris la nécessité que j'avais
de partager ma passion d'échangé à ce
propos est donc cet homme m'a trouvé un
atelier logement dans paris il a fait
plus que ça il m'a aussi permis d'avoir
un métier c'est à dire qu'un jour il
m'appelle et me dit écoutez si vous
voulez travailler je donner votre nom
dans l'école de mon fils est un poste
d'enseignant d'arts plastiques qui s'est
libérée
donc si vous voulez travailler vous
appeler ce soir et advienne que pourra
donc j'ai appelé j'ai été prise
maintenant ça fait quatre ans que j'ai
un atelier logement
j'ai un métier avec un salaire et donc
j'ai cessé de survivre pour me mettre à
vivre et ça c'est très important
et puis comme vous tous il ya deux ans
et bien la panda mis la pandémie nous
est tombé dessus
et avec la pandémie il ya eu le
confinement et ce confinement nous a
permis à tous de prendre du recul sur
nos vies alors c'était plus ou moins
faciles plus ou moins douloureux mais au
moins on a eu la possibilité de
s'extraire y ait eu un temps suspendu et
un philosophe qui s'appelle eric fiat
qu'a écrit une ode à la fatigue aidant
cette ode à la fatigue il traite de
l'authie youm loti youm c'est un temps
de repos où vous vous rendez disponible
à la contemplation à la réflexion
artistique
vous vous rendez disponible à
l'essentiel et dans ce temps de
disponibilité à l'essentiel je me suis
rendu compte que mon essentiel au delà
de l'art c'était la peinture et la
peinture et bien j'ai arrêté de peindre
en un intégrant les beaux-arts en
rentrant aux beaux-arts parce que quand
je suis entré au bozar j'ai compris
c'est une pratique considérée comme
réactionnaire il était de mauvais goût
de peindre est encore plus de pintes du
figuratif que c'était vraiment has been
et s'il ya bien une chose qu'un étudiant
aux beaux-arts ne veut pas porter c'est
vraiment l'étiquette de réac voilà donc
j'ai comme un bon petit soldat j'ai
assimilé tous les diktats qu'on m'a
qu'on m'a transmis et j'ai fait de l'art
conceptuel j'ai fait de l'art conceptuel
et puis j'ai voyagé je me suis adapté
sans cesse parce qu'à l'époque je
considérais que être intelligent c'est
être capable de s'adapter et j'avais
besoin de cette reconnaissance
pourquoi je vous parle de ça c'est pour
mettre en évidence que j'étais soumise à
mon habitude
l'habitus tel que le définit pierre
bourdieu le sociologue c'est la somme de
vos origines de vos origines sociales
c'est à dire qu'en fonction de votre
milieu en fonction de votre culture de
votre éducation vous portez dans votre
corps et dans votre mental bah tout tout
ce qu'on vous a transmis je vous donne
un exemple très simple pour illustrer un
peu mon propos c'est à dire que le mois
dernier il ya à paris il ya eu paris
photo c'est une foire d'art et on m'a
donné un pass vip pour faciliter
l'entrée dans cet événement et
j'attendais je rentrais il ya un
vestiaire pour les vip donc j'attends
derrière monsieur qui déposait ses
affaires et la une qu'a surgi et qui est
rentré directement qu'à déposer ses
affaires sur le comptoir en passant
devant ça c'est l'habitude ce d'où elle
vient elle attend pas et rentre elle
pose en s'occupe d'elle d'où je viens
j'attends mon to pass vip ou pas donc je
vais quand même signifié que sa place
était derrière moi et qu'elle ferait
bien d'attendre son tour est bien là
aussi ça a été une autre révélation
entre guillemets de l'habitus c'est
qu'elle a été choqué car j'étais très
courtoise elle a été choquée que je la
contrarie et elle m'a regardé avec
stupeur voilà c'est ça l'habitus
l'habitus vous en parle parce qu'en fait
d'où vous venez ça va conditionner votre
ambition
généralement on définit notre ambition
en rapport avec les chances qu'on a
d'atteindre cette ambition et moi d'où
je viens ben on se posait pas la
question du milieu parce qu'on était
tous à peu près au même niveau et avec
mes camarades des beaux-arts je me
rendais pas compte que dans ma valise
j'avais pas les mêmes outils que un je
m'en rendais pas compte
si plus ou moins c'est à dire qu'un jour
pendant un cours de philosophie notre
professeur nous a présenté surveiller et
punir de foucault donc pendant deux
heures parler de foucauld haute foucault
moi je me dis ouah par foucault
présentes qui veut gagner des millions
et en plus il écrit surveiller punir
brasse paix absolue quoi fin donc gg je
me dis moi c'est pas possible mais un
truc mais rappelle au niveau du temps et
n'est pas possible et donc j'ai lu le
livre entre les mains j'ai découvert que
c'était bien michel foucault et non pas
jean-pierre donc voilà l'habitus c'est
ça c'est le capital culturel aussi je
fais référence encore une fois à pierre
bourdieu bourdieu bourdieu pierre
bourdieu
aujourd'hui j'ai un confort aujourd'hui
je suis dans un état de de confort qui
est nettement supérieur à toutes ces
étapes là sauf que en sortant des
beaux-arts je me suis pas rendu compte
que pour se jeter dans l'inconnu bien
fallait un filet et quand vous vous
jetez dans l'inconnu sans filet soit
vous êtes suicidaire
ça vous êtes ignorant et moi j'ignorais
moi j'étais dans l'ignorance j'ignorais
que pour sauter en parachute et ben il
fallait un parachute j'ai cru que je
pouvais volée mais non non et donc mon
expérience de résidence en résidence
d'avoir la boule au ventre ne pas savoir
où je dors le soir de de fréquenter tous
les canapés de mes amis voilà là j'ai
compris qu'il valait mieux avoir une
sécurité pour pouvoir prendre des
risques et ça ça c'est mon expérience
qu'il n'ya qui me l'a confronté j'ai été
confronté on l'a connue avant de
l'embrasser je les ai vécus dans ma
chair est
aujourd'hui avec cette stabilité
j'ai compris que
le nécessaire c'était se loger se
nourrir aimé être aimés
autrefois quand j'étais un peu plus
jeune quand j'étais jeune pas se mentir
quand j'étais jeune j'ai tout le temps
la nécessité créé l'action la nécessité
qu rédaction je le crois toujours sauf
qu'à l'époque je mélangeais nécessité
est essentielle
l'essentiel c'est l'art c'est la
peinture l'essentiel c'est ce qui donne
du goût à votre existence
mais sans avoir assuré cette nécessité
vous pouvez pas vous mettre dans dance
est essentielle
donc quand j'étais de résidence en
résidence je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est comme à vélo vous devez continuer
à pédaler pour pour tenir debout en fait
non j'étais sur une moto j'étais sur une
moto et quand vous êtes à moto vous
accélérez vous devez regarder loin
devant vous que si vous regardez sur
votre premier votre roue avant vous
tombez donc je regardais loin loin
devant et en fait la question du temps
indispensable il faut pouvoir être
présent là pour entrer en résonance avec
le moment aujourd'hui je peux parce que
j'ai pas fin j'ai pas froid par la cie
fait froid mais normalement j'ai parfois
et je suis pleinement disponible il ya
un dieu grec qui s'appelle kairos kairos
y prend les traits d'un jeune homme avec
une chevelure abondante comme ça quand
vous le rencontrez il ya trois attitudes
possibles soit vous le voyez pas soit
vous le voyez vous ne faites rien soit
vous tendez la main et vous le
saisissent et par le jeu le kairos c'est
l'instant t avant c'est trop tôt après
c'est trop tard on a que le présent mais
c'est ça aussi rentré en résonance et
vous savez avec l'expérience je me rends
compte que le hasard n'existe pas le
hasard c'est se rendre disponible à
l'accident à l'imprévu si quand vous
marchez dans la rue vous avez des
écouteurs et vous regardez vos pieds
vous risquez pas de voir votre ami qui
passe à côté de vous vous n'êtes pas là
donc une fois que vous avez assuré votre
nécessaire vous pouvez vous rendre
disponible à l'essentiel et enfin
embrasser de tout votre être de tout
votre corps l'inconnu merci de me
répéter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]